hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
as long time listeners know we like to
mix it up here at mindscape there's a
lot of different topics we cover
but many of them are a little bit
serious academic
highbrow kind of things but we also like
to have some fun now and again we'll
talk about
cooking or tv shows or whatever today is
one of those
podcasts we're going to have a little
bit of fun now the topic
you wouldn't guess is one of the weird
ones because the topic is very
mindscapey
autonomous vehicles the future of
technology
and self-driving cars but it's not going
to be about
the technology itself we're going to
talk about the human
side of what this means what this means
what it will mean
in the future what it is meaning right
now to give up our control
over our vehicles from ourselves to the
artificially intelligent
robots so our guest today is jason
torchinski
jason is not a phd at stanford designing
new radar systems for cars he's a writer
and illustrator a good friend of mine
that i've known for a long time
jason actually did the illustrations for
my book from eternity to here
but more than anything else jason is a
car lover
he's a writer for jalopnik.com and his
most recent book is called
robot take the wheel the road to
autonomous cars and the lost art of
driving so we're talking about here in
today's podcast is
what will it be like for us human beings
to live in a world where cars drive
themselves
a lot of it won't even be driving
ourselves if you have autonomous cars
there's no reason to have a person in
them at all they'll be delivering things
at one point in the podcast jason
fantasized about driving one of his cars
that is liable to break down at any
moment
but he has another car trailing behind
him carrying spare parts
i should also warn sensitive listeners
this is another podcast
where we have naughty language being
used last week with carl bergstrom
it was right there in the title we were
talking about [ __ ] here it's just
for colorful
slice of life kind of purposes so i
think that you'll enjoy this one it's
both something that will make you think
because the
autonomous cars are coming but also
something we can have fun with and with
that
let's go
[Music]
jason torchinski welcome to mindscape
podcast thanks for having me sean i'm
very excited
well you've written this wonderful book
uh full of profanity
and i'm saying that right out loud so
that we know listener-wise this is going
to be rated explicit in the podcast
listings rather than a clean episode but
you know
not egregiously so only when called for
so
your book robot a big fan yeah exactly
it's a tool in the toolbox right um
exactly
robot take the wheel is about autonomous
cars but i
it's not either a book full of
predictions
or although predictions are there nor is
it really a book mostly about the
technology
it's more is it too much to say it's a
book about
our attitudes toward this oncoming thing
that we're going to have to face pretty
soon
yeah i think i think that's a lot closer
i mean
there already are books out there that
covered the tech aspect of it and that's
changing so rapidly
the idea of writing a book about that
just wasn't appealing to me and frankly
i'm just not that
qualified really and as far as raw
predictions go
they rarely turn out the way we think
they will
and i feel like so many of the things
that i see predicted are usually coming
from the
companies themselves that have a vested
interest in these things and i find them
wildly optimistic
and i think they tend to downplay how
complex and interesting a problem this
really is so
i just wanted to avoid all that make
something people are hearing a lot about
it i wanted to give him
some perspective and get them thinking
about it in like a broader sense
and not just in an automotive sense
because they are robots
this will be a mass deployment of robots
into society
like we've never had before yeah yeah no
and you make that point uh very clearly
and we will get there but i think we
have to do at least a little bit of
predicting here i mean
um yeah there are probably people who
think that
within 10 years most cars will be
essentially autonomous and there's
probably
other people who think that within 100
years they won't so you know what
what is your the landscape in your mind
that you're using to sort of feel around
what the important questions are what do
you think is going to be like
20 or 50 years from now you know i
i i think actually the most important
thing as far as that goes is
before i get into 20 or 50 years we have
to talk about
what people think right now at this
moment because there's actually
a lot happening right now that's
extremely dangerous
okay and that is there's a lot of people
right at this moment who do believe
that autonomous cars are already out
there and you can go buy one
and that i think is the biggest issue we
have to overcome even before the
predictions i think we're
we're a ways away we're probably a good
decade away from these things becoming
actually usable and safe enough to just
generally have in the road and maybe 20
years away before they're actually
common and i think even then there's
still going to be a lot of restrictions
but the biggest issue right now is that
they don't exist
at this moment not really not in the way
everybody likes to think of them
um and companies like tesla is
the i think the biggest offender here
are doing a lot to muddy the waters
you know their autopilot set up they
have on their website it says
you know full self driving that's an
option you can check when you're buying
yourself a new tesla
and that's dangerously not the case
that's that's the label that they give
it those are their words
yeah those are labels they give i mean
it's called autopilot which is
a a confusing name for most people
autopilot when people hear that they
think
autopilot the car will drive itself they
think maybe about a plane autopilot or
something like that
and um you know these the level of
autonomy that you're
that a tesla has actually that any you
know vulva has systems gm has a system
tesla has systems nissan they've all got
autonomous like systems but they're just
level
what would be known as level two
autonomy which means the driver
has to be aware and in control
or at least ready to take control at a
moment's notice it is not
it is not fully autonomous by any
stretch and
that confusion is why you see news
reports of people
in tesla's on the highway sleeping and
you know reading or something like that
and there's a number of wrecks that have
happened
where these cars have been on you know
autopilot
and encountered a situation that they
didn't know how to deal with that
normally
you would as a driver in the car should
be ready to take over but people
believing these things were more than
they are you know weren't able to
well also even at the best of times i
mean that just sounds like a very
difficult position to be in to be in a
car
that is mostly driving itself but you
are nevertheless
expected to stand ready to jump in like
that's harder than actually driving in
some sense
a hundred i absolutely agree in fact
there's a whole chapter in my book i
have
about how semi-autonomy is stupid which
is
by semi-autonomy i'm referring the level
two systems
that um cars like tesla and gm's uh
super crews use right now
and i think it's fundamentally stupid
because it's
incompatible with how humans actually
work like if something's doing 80
of the work and they it's there's a
demand
on the person who's in this system where
a machine is doing 80
of the work to be alert and ready to
take over at any moment
that's just not how humans operate we
don't work that way
like if something's doing most of the
work once it shows us that it's probably
basically okay we relax we turn off
that's why there are people
reading or watching movies behind the
tesla because it is on a clear
open highway it's doing about 80 percent
of the work of driving and that's
kind of enough for a an awful lot of
highway driving
but crucially it is not
absolutely everything and it is not
enough to go on and people just
we just don't work that way i'm and it
is it is i find it harder like when
you're driving
like just driving you go into like a
kind of this state of where muscle
memory takes over
it's something you've been doing for
years and you know so you react before
even thinking about it like when you
drive
and something jumps in front of your car
you don't immediately have to do like
math and process where it's going your
body just does it your car is
very much a prosthetic and that it's an
extension of you you make a motion
very quickly and instinctively you turn
the wheel you hit the brake and you move
if you're in a system where the car is
expected to be handling most of that and
you're kind of
you have to have your hands on your
wheel but you're also not supposed to be
steering
it's a weird space to be in it's an
unnatural state
and i've driven in these cars and i hate
it i hate being on
this autopilot mode i would if my hands
have to be on the wheel and i have to be
sitting
and looking and paying attention i may
as well just drive the damn thing
like just [ __ ] drive like you're
already there you don't get to sleep
just drive the damn car and i bet that
there is actually a neuroscientific uh
explanation for this in terms of you
know both
sort of system one versus system two our
unconscious versus our conscious but
also
the map in our heads of what constitutes
our
physical uh self that we can use to
explore the world like
they're like i think it's more than just
a metaphor when you say that we're in
the car we think of it as an extension
of our body
like we get sensory input from it and it
reacts to us and so forth and
if you break that connection it's a
different kind of interaction it's much
more cognitive much more system two
and that's way harder to maintain over
long periods of time
i think that's a really good point yeah
because when you're just normally
driving
i actually talk about car as a
prosthetic as a body extension
in here a lot cause that's what driving
does become you
wear a car in a sense you you are
physically doing things
and they have direct actions you push
your your foot down
you push down your right foot and you go
faster you know you you
push the brake or the clutch or the
other foot and you feel something happen
immediately
you move your arms it's all and your
body gets used to these reactions and i
think you're right you're not
it is much more of you know system one
kind of thinking you're
you're just doing things and they happen
and it's
physical yeah but the semi-autonomous
space is a completely different thing
you're
managing a system in a stepped-back way
and it's you're not going to have the
immediacy of reaction
it doesn't feel natural and i don't
think it's a good way to fundamentally
pilot
a moving thing so just so because i've
never really followed up
uh or followed these news reports very
carefully i mean there are
stories of people in tesla's or other
vehicles getting into trouble
but on the other hand there are many
stories that don't get published of
people
driving cars getting into trouble right
like is there some feeling for whether
at the current state of the art these
actually are safer or less safe
than just driving a regular old car well
it's tricky because
car driving is dangerous no question
about it people get into accidents
all the damn time every bit of the time
i mean absolutely
i've met people and i'm i'm incredibly
surprised that people don't die even
more often than they do
like the idea of just giving people a
ton of metal moving at very fast speeds
and hoping for the best is it's a little
bit crazy if you didn't already have it
established in the world
oh yeah i mean yeah actually if you were
to be completely rat like
one of the things the reason i'm a car
an automotive journalist and the reason
i love cars is because
they are fundamentally irrational things
in
every possible sense they if you were an
alien and landed here
and you know you said and you went to
explain to this alien how
the personal transportation system works
in the world
they would be stopping you after the
first five minutes and go whoa whoa whoa
what the hell are you guys doing
gorgeous
why would you do it this way yeah i mean
i mean if you think about the way we
choose to buy cars makes no sense the
fact that cars like for example
i drive a car my daily driver is this
little weird
japanese market nissan pal it makes 53
horsepower
it's fine i get everywhere i need to go
just fine i can go on the highway i
could do
75 miles an hour but the audience our
audience needs to know that you are
special
in this in this particular way like you
are not representative of the car
driving public in any way
no i am not and that's going to be lead
to my point which is that
most cars today have two to throw not
even like three
to ten times the power of this car like
it is we don't buy cars for rational
reasons
we don't drive rational vehicles if it
all made sense it was rational
they you know they would be like five
different kinds of cars parts would be
interchangeable
they styling wouldn't matter but cars
aren't like that
there's something much more human about
them and they're closer in some ways to
fashion
than they are other things we buy like
you can have a refrigerator for 30 years
and when you get rid of it you don't
care but pretty much everybody i know
has either shed a tear or come close to
shedding tears when they've gotten rid
of a car they've had for a long time i
did that
i recently changed cars and it was a it
was a heartbreaking experience like
it's a lot of your life you used to have
did you get rid of your jacket i did
yeah yeah yeah trade it in for a little
electric bmw
i3 which is like the opposite end of car
land from
my uh v8 convertible jaguar but uh
fun in its own way but either way
there's a strong emotional connection
too absolutely and you also spend a lot
of time in like a lot of people
half an hour an hour commute either way
that's a lot of your life
that is spent in that vehicle yeah no
it's a big deal and even people who
claim they don't care about cars
there's plenty of people say oh i don't
care what i drive i guarantee you we can
find a vehicle that they do not want to
be seen in
like there's someone if they say they
don't care about cars and they say okay
great i'm going to loan you this hummer
with gold wheels that i'd like you to
drive around for a day
they would go uh i don't really want
anyone to see me getting out of that
thing
like you say it's much more like wearing
clothes right it is definitely part of
who you are even if you
disclaim that yeah you are making a
statement about who you are with your
your vehicle and now i've kind of
forgotten
we're trying to we're trying to get to
whether or not they really are safe
right now compared to the terrible lack
of safety in regular cars
yeah i mean look driving's not safe
driving's never been 100
safe it probably never will be 100 safe
you're moving a human
body at speeds far beyond the warranty
like we were never meant to do
any of this crap we were good at running
in fields and
chasing gazelle or whatever the hell we
did but this is
all all outside of the warranty so it's
not safe
now autonomous cars the big argument
that's always made and the
the hardcore tesla stands and the people
who get mad at you on twitter whenever
you say anything bad about elon musk one
of the things they always come back to
is that
he's saving lives and if you're not you
know 100
behind these autonomous vehicle plans
then you're
killing people but maybe that'll be true
in the future
at this moment that's not true at all
and even for all the miles that i mean
we don't there hasn't been a deployment
of 100 autonomous vehicles on the road
yet i mean there have been
tests and google has fleets and things
like that but it's all under pretty
controlled circumstances
really there's people in there watching
and guiding and
even though they may have millions of
miles racked up it doesn't even hold a
candle
to how many just person miles happen
every day in the world
of millions and millions of people
driving cars everywhere yeah
and it's at this moment
we're not there yet i mean look okay you
could argue somebody falling asleep at
the wheel
of a conventionally driven car it's
going to end badly
no matter what but it'll end badly
quickly you know
it will end badly probably within
minutes of them really falling asleep at
the wheel you're not going to drive very
far
before you're going to run into
something or hurt someone or heal
yourself
in something like a tesla or another
vehicle with level 2 autonomy on like an
open highway
you can fall asleep and there's a chance
you'll be okay
there's a chance you'll be okay there's
a chance you'll go two hours of driving
before you wake up and realize holy crap
i've been asleep
there's also a chance you could drive
for a half hour and then run into
a much bigger group of people like at
best i think where we are right now
you have maybe a buffer maybe
there's a bigger buffer of safety uh
that you're allowed because there's some
compensatory
work that the vehicle is doing but i
don't know if we're really at the point
where i can 100 say you're absolutely
safer because
look it could be you fall asleep at the
wheel of your car you run off the road
almost immediately it's done
you fall asleep at the wheel of a tesla
you could end up going from an area of
sparse population and traffic density
into one that's higher like
and then causing even more trouble and
people have been killed
behind the wheel of cars that were you
know like tesla's driving themselves in
level
two like it's happened it's not like a
hypothetical so
it's a complex system it's complex and
right now i don't think we're at the
point where we can 100
say the cars are doing a better job of
not killing people
we're not there yet they could but
not yet a great way to keep
extending your knowledge base is to look
at courses from the great courses plus
the grade courses plus is an extremely
convenient streaming service
offering you very simple access to a
wide variety
of courses taught by professors of the
great courses plus
it goes from the depths of the ocean to
the history of egypt to the study of dna
and new courses are being added all the
time so there's something for everyone
if you're interested in the kind of
thing we're talking about on the podcast
today
automation in the future there's a good
course by tim chartier called
big data how data analytics is
transforming
the world it gives you a little bit of a
peek into the nuts and bolts of
artificial intelligence systems
and how they're being used in modern
technology and now
mindscape listeners can check out any
course or lecture
for free at the great courses plus if
you sign up using a special url
you get free access to the entire
library so start your free trial at the
great courses plus
dot com slash mindscape that's t-h-e
great courses p-l-u-s dot com slash
mindscape start learning today
that's fair i mean the other thing is
you uh have been using this
this uh phraseology level two and i
don't know if that's
just your uh classification system or if
that's universally accepted but why
don't you let us in on what the
classification
levels are sure yeah so that's that's
from the society of automotive engineers
is where this comes from
uh it's a uh basically a five level
setup so yeah this is a good thing to
explain so level one
is uh completely manual car like there's
no
no autonomy features at all maybe level
1.5 you could say cruise control
because the car is handling um you know
the throttle aspect you know a little
bit and then dynamic crews
we're probably edging on level two where
it keeps the same distance level two
autonomy
is the highest you can buy commercially
right now and that would be like
tesla autopilot gm supercruise that kind
of thing where
um the car can do things like it's
basically a combination of lane keeping
um it does some visual cognition where
it like re has a camera feed
it reads lines it can see if something's
coming in front of it and it can
slow down or stop um it does dynamic
crews where it keeps the set distance
between another vehicle
so it does some but level two also means
it can fail at any moment with zero
warning that's why it's in that weird
space we were talking about
where you have to be ready to take over
at any moment and that's why
teslas require people to have their
hands on the steering wheel
while the system is active although
people have done things like
you can shove an orange in the wheel and
that could override it and somebody was
actually selling this thing called an
autopilot buddy that you just hung on
the steering wheel
and it mimicked the weight of hands in
the wheel so there's all kinds of really
serious
ways yeah that gm is doing something
different but they have a camera
pointing at your face
where they watching your eyes and if
your eyes deviate from the road then it
sets off warnings and stuff
and i think also i bet if they ever go
to court that they would
uh use that in their favor or something
like that too i don't even know
what are these are these supposed to be
able to
also park the car stop the traffic
lights and start and things like that
um level two could encompass stopping at
traffic lights and things like that
tesla
just um i think the recent beta
just just allows for traffic light
stopping
um otherwise that's and actually it's
funny because
it was they added in a thing for it to
read stop signs and traffic lights and
things like that
and uh somebody had was recording where
it was reading a burger king sign
as like a traffic slow down thing and it
was slowing down by this burger king
sign and then burger king
used that in some ad campaigns so if you
were in a tesla
and you could prove that your car
automatically stopped at a burger king
they'd give you a whopper
something like that very good and
i was playing so and actually like the
uh traffic sign recognition shows up on
a lot more cars that even don't have
these systems there was um
mazda uses it and then on their little
heads up display if there's a stop sign
they'll show an icon of the sign that
shows up and just with um
magic marker i drew a sign that said
slop
and it put it up and it uh you know it
fooled the system so
these are there's all kinds of potential
for shenanigans with this stuff because
it's very easy to fool these things
their
artificial intelligence is still pretty
stupid when it comes to a lot of things
but
um and can it park can can you
in principle do that yeah like if you
were just throwing caution to the wind
could i
get into the car in my driveway tell it
to
drive to someone else's driveway and and
not touch the wheel the whole time is
that current technology
i don't think you can go driveway to
driveway but you can there's
a bunch of cars have self-parking
systems where they can go into parallel
parking spots
or other spots tesla even has a summon
mode
uh where you can be in a parking lot
like a big parking lot in front of like
a supermarket or something and you could
summon the car to come
out of the parking lot and then come to
you tracking you by your phone
which actually that it kind of amazes me
that this is allowed to be done at all
because it's
insane if you think about it oh yeah
because okay a parking lot is not
technically
on the road um this is just a beta
system
and they're all they're letting people
do it and this is and when it came out
a number of like mid last year there are
people putting all kinds of videos of
these things going the wrong way
down these sections it's very impressive
technology
but at the same time it's not really
finished and they're
basically beta testing this in public
live
like if i had a 2500 pound remote
control car
and i said hey i want to play with this
in the parking lot of a target
and just [ __ ] around with it and see
what would be fun i would get arrested
in seconds they wouldn't let me do that
but that that's literally what you're
doing with this tesla summon mode it's
it's not different but somehow
they uh do it and it's no one's been
killed or anything but
there have been plenty of close calls
and it's it's a remote controlled car
but but
but a big one yeah anyway it's a
full-size car
so then what's level three what's that
level yes level three so level three
is very similar to level two but it
doesn't
it can fail safely so level three means
you can it can basically drive on its
own
uh but if it encounters a situation
where it
fails or it gets bad input or it can't
deal
where level two would require the driver
to immediately take over
level three will have some kind of
system for it to fail
fail over in an elegant way either pull
over
carefully to the side or something
similar i don't think
a bunch of companies have come pretty
close to level three i know volvo was
playing with the system that they
claimed could
safely pull over but if you're on a
highway this is still a difficult
problem
um if you're on a highway and you don't
have a good shoulder
uh being able to fail over safely is
still tricky you can't just
stop so if something happens like
remember because these things are
relying on
lidar sensor well i guess tesla doesn't
use lidar but cameras and
some of them are using lidar if mud gets
flung onto a camera lens and you can't
see
where humans are pretty good at
squeezing you know squinting through the
wipers and
kind of you know we have you know
millennia of
evolution to make us good at figuring
out what we're seeing
these things don't have that and if you
know they lose most of their vision
um they don't have a lot of choice they
just kind of have to stop safely so
level three is like level two but you
don't have to take over it can handle
stopping without everyone ending up dead
um and this is
this uh it recalls a couple of
conversations we've had here on the
podcast before
on uh about artificial intelligence and
its
struggles and shortcomings um we don't
have the ability yet to teach computers
common sense or a
feeling for the world around us that
that is somehow
takes into account what we all are born
knowing about you know solid objects and
how they
behave i remember seeing one
demonstration of
a machine learning program that was
really really good at telling the
difference between dogs and wolves
but it turns out that it wasn't even
looking at the dogs in the wolves it was
just looking at the background and you
know the wolves are always in nature and
in the snow and things like that and the
dogs are in backyards and so
take a picture of a husky out there in
the snow and it's like that's clearly a
wolf
yeah and that's very a little bit
worrisome it is because a lot of these
are black box kind of systems we don't
really know
what's going on in those weird brains in
there so it's
i know honestly artificial intelligence
is always a term i found
questionable because it's not really
it's not even artificial intelligence
it's more like
mimicry of intelligence or something
like that it's
the processes are so different and i
think in driving
we get this even more because there's so
many human aspects to driving which we
should talk
after i go through these levels we
should we should talk about all those
subtle things
because i think it's that's what makes
it really fascinating and i think
if you want to say like okay the first
20 years of autonomous driving
development got us to like
70 percent this last 30 or 20 percent
is where the really strange and subtle
stuff is going to happen and i think
that's what's going to really take a
while
yeah that's true with everything but
good okay level four level four
is it can basically do anything drive
just like a person you get in say go
wherever i want to go
but it's in a geo-fenced area like
you've basically established
a corridor of a situation where you know
you can kind of control the
circumstances
but the car in that circumstance can
pretty much do anything
i've been in a system like this a test
system where they basically had a
retirement community and these little
golf cart like vehicles
that were autonomous but it was an
extremely controlled situation
after we were in there we took it out
into this was outside of boston
we took it into boston traffic and the
thing freaked out immediately at the
first roundabout we went to
because it's programmed to be extremely
polite
and part of driving involves taking
risks
risks you don't know the output of like
whenever you go
on like in a roundabout there's always a
point where a car is coming at you
and you just have to decide i'm just
gonna go you just hit the gas and do it
and you take a little bit of risk
hopefully they can deal with
what's that hopefully they can deal with
it the other driver exactly and
you are relying on the other driver to
not panic and all that stuff and
most of the time it works fine
occasionally it doesn't um
but this system used to its geofenced
area
in uh all in like a retirement community
surrounded mostly by
other vehicles like it that every that
were friendly
and polite um it got along there fine
but once it got in the real world it
freaked out it's like a kid who'd been
homeschooled and then you throw him into
like a brutal high school situation and
you know the first day he's gonna come
home in tears and
to be fair i i kind of freak out when
i'm asked to drive in the boston area
also as someone who was there for many
years
it's a little bit anomalous yeah it's
not easy but i mean
there's plenty of cities like that uh
and then level five is the hypothetical
platonic ideal of just the complete
robotic car you get in
say where you want to go and it figures
everything out
and for the for even at level four we
could imagine i mean maybe one of the
steps along the way
is uh we have specialized highways that
only
autonomous vehicles are allowed to go on
and the speed limit is 250 miles an hour
and uh and and we don't expect them to
sort of stop the traffic lights or
anything like that but
is that do you think that that's a
reasonable stepping stone along the way
to uh autonomous vehicle hood i think
that definitely could happen um
i think you know and i i cover this in
the book too kind of from a perspective
of someone who
wants to keep driving as a human uh
because i feel like that's
that kind of compromise uh offers a you
know is that's the biggest threat to
human driving in the sense like there
may come a point
where the tipping point is that more
people would rather
have their cars drive for them than
drive themselves and then all of a
sudden i could see human drivers
getting forced out of highways that get
turned into autonomous vehicle only
highways which
are you know marked and designed for
autonomous vehicle travel
relying on the car to car communications
that would be happening
you could have very high speeds i mean
in a lot of ways
it becomes something close to a mass
transit system really just with
independent
uh pods or cars because that's kind of
what makes the most most sense
for highway-like corridors all these
things should be ganging up together and
communicating with one another
to form basically mass transit kind of
setups and then
people still have individual ability to
break off of the main group and then go
their own separate ways but that maybe
necessitate
no humans around yeah well no humans
controlling anything yeah
um and you also you invented your own
level six
to this list of levels right oh yeah
yeah that's right i left
my level six what was six level six is
where the card
decides where it wants to go oh yeah
yeah where it actually decides where to
take you right where you don't even have
you don't even tell the destination
anymore
level six is where you just trust the
car for anything because you just assume
it's gonna know better than you where
you should be going
we laugh but uh that might be coming up
who knows
um okay i mean i think also i do want to
get into the human aspects of of driving
and inter interfacing maybe maybe even
driving isn't
the right word but uh we should also
share with the audience a little bit
about the technology
that that enables these things you
mentioned ai
i mean you mentioned the cars talking to
each other is that i take it that is
not part of most current systems
not not to the extent that a lot of
people are saying it should be they
usually call this
car to car c2c sometimes but um
the thinking is for this to work really
well
every like there has to be a constant
web of communication between vehicles
we do it to some degree now i mean turn
signals
are a version of this and even looking
you know if you ever do well you you're
you live in l.a so you know in l.a
utility has its own few unspoken rules
about driving i remember
when i lived in la um if i wanted to
merge
into like a line of slow-moving traffic
or whatever
uh the trick was you got if you made eye
contact with the person in the car
there was an unspoken rule and it worked
99 of the time the person would let you
in
in front of them but sometimes they
would really avoid eye contact because
they didn't want to do it but they knew
once that eye contact was established
it happened and i remember remember
staring at one guy once really wanting
to get in and he finally broke and made
eye contact and he made that kind of
exasperated god i gotta let that in
you let me know because he knows that's
the rule
la also has the rule of um uh three
people
can turn on turn left at a red light
you know about this sean well i see i've
always heard it as two people
so you are trying to push the idea that
three cars can go through a red light
turning left
uh after yeah i always read i've always
heard three that was my uh
okay but i mean this is it's a lot but
i've
i feel like i've consistently lived in
la like 20 years almost and i feel like
i consistently
would see three going at the red but
it's not a rule that's written anywhere
it's just
some degree of that rule two or three
some degree that you allow some people
to go through in the red
is an unspoken agreed upon rule
among the drivers that's part of what's
going to be fascinating to teach
autonomous vehicles because they they
won't understand this
these folk laws that we have are things
that
they don't get that all the gestures
that we make
through windows and through uh you know
when we look at each other while we're
driving which we do all the time
uh you know all of those are things that
these cars won't get and i know i'm
getting away from the technology
but no no but this is but it relates
immediately back to the technology
because
so if i if i push back a little bit and
i play the role of the techno utopian
now
um once the cars are talking to each
other and we can let them all
sort of do a little bit of deep learning
on what happens as they go through the
streets
the cars will evolve their own ways of
signaling
sort of implicit rules that are not
written into the traffic code but
nevertheless
maybe make things more efficient that's
i think that is true if you had
a system where all the cars were talking
to each other we need
you know agreed upon standards which is
tricky and
that also leads this like this is the
thing i love about autonomous vehicles
that the more you dig the more complex
this gets because we're we're about to
enter an even more sticky situation
like discussion where if these cars are
talking to each other
and they're going to come up with their
own set of criteria and rules to make
for more efficient traffic flow
that means there needs to be an
overarching
set of rules and criteria and you know
these are
this is edging on azimovian laws of
robotics like
do the cars prioritize their own
occupants or do they
prioritize the good of the people around
them how do they make these value calls
and there's been a lot of fascinating
research done on all this stuff you get
into the
the trolley problem
yeah exactly and that's like it comes up
yeah i had to address it in the book
because
it always comes up even though it's kind
of absurd and you're very
unlikely to have to actually encounter
it but i'm not sure what happened
i'm pretty sure that like 10 years ago
no one had heard of the trolley problem
and now
it's just part of pop culture i'm not
quite sure how it got there i know it
was in the good place but it predates
that
oh yeah it predates that i mean i think
autonomous cars did a lot to popularize
it because
the rise of because like that's the big
thing where people start thinking about
it i mean
why would we have brought it up before
then really okay the trolley problem is
hilariously
it's kind of a hilarious thing to read
about because the various levels of it
like there's one where they talk about
pushing a fat guy under the tracks
to stop the train yeah that's right let
me pause for a second to talk about the
number one
job site in the world indeed.com
one of the great challenges you face if
you're going to hire people
is that you need all the information you
can get and also
know where to focus with indeed you have
access to the largest pool of talent and
can hire the right people fast
unlike other sites indeed gives you full
control and payment flexibility over
your hiring
you need only pay for what you need you
can pause the account at any time
and there are no long-term contracts
with 73
of online job seekers visiting indeed
each month
indeed it's going to let you get the
important hire you need
just like they have for over 3 million
businesses and right now
indeed is offering mindscape listeners a
free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means more quality candidates will see
it
fast try it out with free 75
credit at indeed.com mindscape this is
the best offer available anywhere
so go right now to indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30 terms and conditions apply the
this is this is worth just saying out
loud i think it is kind of fascinating i
mean the trolley problem is not supposed
to teach you something
about ethics it's just supposed to
remind you that we have competing
ethical instincts and it's not clear
how to resolve them right and i think
that it's almost
right it's almost misapplied for
self-driving cars because
uh hopefully if a self-driving car has
an
option of killing one person or killing
five people it will kill one person and
this is probably hopefully very rare
that it even has that choice but
if you read asimov's stories about the
robots
where the real tension comes because all
the stories are about how his laws of
robotics don't work
in some sense right there's some some uh
way in which they fail
so you know what if the completely
autonomous vehicle
sees a terrorist who's about to do
something terrible like does the
autonomous vehicle have the positive uh
responsibility of taking out the
terrorist to save a whole bunch of
people
rather than just letting the terrorists
do the terrible things that's where
things get a little bit freaky i think
yeah and actually i i address this
directly in the book like
should we make them heroic like here's
here's the thought okay and i go through
this little thought experiment in the
book
okay if let's say we're at some point in
the future where
autonomous cars form a population of
like they're 20
of the traffic of general life and
let's say you know there was that
situation in like toronto where that guy
drove like a rented u-haul truck into a
huge crowd of people
if that if what if you could sign up
when you register your car in the same
way you sign up as an organ donor now
you could check a box that says in
certain situations
my car is allowed to be conscripted for
the greater good
so if there could be something where
like they see a guy in a rented u-haul
is going to drive into a big crowd of
people at a street fair or something
if say like six cars are in between
the path of that truck and the group of
people and one of them is yours and you
could have said okay
what if your cars could be used to form
a roadblock to
keep that truck from getting to where it
wants to go um
like that's a thing that we could do um
if an ambulance is coming down the
street it could be sending a signal to
all the autonomous vehicle traffic
to either get out of the way or possibly
even like a sheepdog
heard other traffic out of the way to
form a path for
the ambulance so it can get to its
location quicker there's actually a lot
of applications
where heroism could be programmed into
these vehicles
we just have to decide do we want to do
it are people willing
to potentially risk if it's a privately
owned car
you know do we let them you know do they
want to take that risk or do we mandate
if a company runs a fleet of
self-driving taxis that they all
have to agree to be heroic in certain
extreme situations
i think it's a fascinating concept well
it also it does
i think it's sort of psychologically
illuminating because even without
knowing what the answer is when you say
uh i could imagine being in a
self-driving car that is programmed to
get out of the way for ambulances
that you think oh yeah okay that's not
so bad i could i could probably live
with that but then when you say
what if all the other cars on the road
are self-driving and they are programmed
to sheepdog me out of the way when an
ambulance comes
suddenly you feel like your personal
autonomy is being a bit threatened here
yeah and i mean it is it would you would
be giving up a little bit of autonomy
with that
if your private property could be
destroyed in the service of the greater
good
i think most of us would probably say
they'd be willing to do that but you are
giving up some
some degree of autonomy and you know the
idea of prioritizing the occupants
like are we going to have one set of
rules or is it going to be like each
manufacturer
gets to decide like is it just going to
be the kind of thing where you know
if you buy an expensive enough car the
people inside will be prioritized more
than
the people outside or can you make these
settings on your own in like a
you know a settings option panel in the
dashboard or something like that
and how will it work if we allow people
to make their own
you know if we don't have a hard and
fast set of rules for something like
that
it gets messy fast we live in a country
where people have trouble wearing masks
in the middle of a global pandemic so
i'm not at all optimistic they're going
to turn over the autonomy of their cars
i know and when i wrote this book you
know i wrote this book
i guess a year before last came out last
year but when i wrote it we weren't in a
pandemic yeah nobody was talking about
masks
and i think i was a little more
optimistic but yeah seeing how people
react to masks
is very disheartening these are not the
same these are not the people who are
going to prioritize
the greater good when it comes to their
car if there's a setting for them to
kill everyone around them to make sure
they get out through okay
they will anyway and then there's you
know fear yeah
lidar cameras how do these work how do
the
cars know what's around them and who to
hit and who not to hit
okay so a lot of different systems in
these things um
uh right now the most common way is
visual there's cameras
and almost every modern new car has a
camera set up in it that could be used
for some
semi-autonomy um every car that does
lane keeping for example which is
extremely common now
almost any every car maker i think makes
a car lane keeping
basically behind the rear view mirror on
your windshield there's a camera
it's looking at the street and it's
basically using visual processing
algorithms to see where the lanes are
um on an autonomous car it's using
similar kinds of ai to take images from
the camera
identify what's likely to be a car
what's likely to be a person walking
lane markings street signs that kind of
thing and it uses that to help drive and
steer the car
a lot of the a lot of the
images of like cars and people are done
kind of proportionally like
uh cars tend to be a certain scale
and a certain kind of proportion and a
guy on a guy walking or a woman walking
is another basic you know taller
rectangle
someone on a bike is a certain kind of
rectangle speed and distance all these
things are factored in so there's a big
visual component and that's
a lot of the hardware in the car a lot
of the image processing computing power
is for the this uh for reading what the
camera's sending
and yet i'm surprised to read in your
car that you know the cameras aren't
that great
they're nowhere near as good as human
eyeballs and and
that seems like an obvious place for
improvement i don't know maybe it just
is not
uh worth the cost i'm not sure i mean
they're
i think if like the quality is basically
like from a webcam
like you know 10 years ago really i
think if they're doing
1024 by 768 resolution i think that's
even on the high side i don't think they
do much more than that really um
it's the image quality isn't that great
and you know it's it doesn't but it
doesn't need
that much detail really although there
have been cases where these things get
fooled like if you
have a photograph there was a study in
the mit did they had a van
with pictures of bicycles on it and that
was very easy to fool these autonomous
cars
uh they would immediately think these
were bicycles on the car like they're
that's just again all things that humans
would never be fooled by
yeah but that's they're they're trying
hard and like like you said before
shenanigans right i mean there are ways
that uh
people with not completely um
noble intentions could make life hard
for these autonomous vehicles
absolutely i mean it's like having a
very competent toddler driving some of
these in a way either
they can do it but they're easy to fool
at the same time
um and then there's lidar so lidar uh
famously rejected by elon musk he didn't
want to use lidar
um i think possibly for aesthetic
reasons because it usually requires a
funny looking dome on the top of the car
but it's
it's like laser-based radar it's
basically uh it shoots lasers in like a
360 degree
um you know well i guess a circle or
dome around the car
and it's recording the time to bounce
back so lighter is very good for
doing distance ranging and seeing things
even if the visual conditions aren't
necessarily that
great so lidar gives a good overall
view of everything around the car in a
very three-dimensional way
and it it would be working with um
camera input to you know to um
approximate that you give the give the
car a sense of where it is
and then you have things like ultrasonic
sensors which are mostly used for
close quarters kind of thing parking um
reading what's very close to you
there's also radar which is usually used
for keeping
the distance between the car and a
vehicle in front of it
uh usually those are just front mounted
radar emitters
um these are you know yeah that's most
of the systems and of course there's all
the computing power needed to run it and
ideally in the future there probably
will be communications equipment
um i mean there already are there's gps
also i mean it is crocking the
satellites to know where it is and know
where to go gps
is crucial for this and it can use gps
um and pre pre-existing data about the
roads
so it kind of knows what's coming up and
can predict certain things
about the roads and even that could be
updated
you know if there's systems in place to
give it like information and that
changes rapidly like
there's construction here and it's down
to one lane uh that information
hypothetically could be sent to cars
prior to them driving uh i think
cadillac was using a system for a while
where they were doing a sort of higher
level autonomy on
roads that they had vetted that they
knew and were in a database
that was sent to the car so they could
drive them with more confidence but of
course that doesn't help for
you know random things that could happen
other drivers logs that fall on the road
you know
cattle trucks overturning anything like
that i mean these days most of us
are carrying around personal gps devices
that are in constant
communication with the rest of the world
uh in the form of our phones
i could imagine very easily hooking up
the phone to
a car and letting it share that info you
must have seen the guy who was carrying
around a whole bunch of iphones in a
little
uh uh toy uh wagon and then
google thought it was a traffic jam on
that street because of
all those phones yeah that's right which
is amazing
yeah yeah that guy was awesome yeah it's
um
so i mean and the other thing is uh
some of these other things that don't
seem to get thought about very often
though
um even with all these sensors being
really good you have to keep them clean
um we're really good as people at
driving through
hard rain and snow and icy conditions
like you most
of us driving in cold weather ice we
scrape out a hole in the windshield
and we're pretty much good to go um it's
not necessarily the best way our v you
know we're driving more carefully
we're maybe trying to be a little more
aware but a good ice storm will
keep most autonomous vehicles from going
anywhere
unless they have systems in place to
heat and melt ice off
radar emitters and camera sensors and
things like that like
you're gonna have to keep these things
clean
but so it sounds like a big a big part
of the challenge then is
uh just like human beings the cars are
multi-sensory right you have the lidar
and
i mean do you personally think that
lidar will be part of future autonomous
vehicles or will elon be right
and you can get away with just cameras
now i think i think you're going to need
lidar
lidar does provide a lot more
information than just a camera feed just
a better
three-dimensional map of what's around
you elevation changes
things that are also confusing visually
lidar wouldn't get fooled for example
one of the
there's been at least two fatal wrecks
of people in teslas on autopilot
where a it's basically been a down
open highway in bright clear weather
conditions
but a white truck has been going
perpendicular
like coming out of a gas station or
across the road and the camera
wasn't able to discern the white's truck
you know body itself you know like a
tractor-trailer truck
the the trailer part it wasn't able to
discern it from the
sky and the card is basically slammed
right into it
um lidar would have prevented something
like that because it would have read it
as a three
large three-dimensional object in the
way so i think
the more systems you have more sensory
systems you have
acting as backups to one another is
always going to be better
but so what you're saying is future cars
are all going to have laser domes on the
top that doesn't sound like a bad thing
to me i mean that sounds like an
improvement
i think that'll be kind of cool and i've
seen um they're getting smaller and
there have been some designs i've seen
where they're incorporating them better
and if you don't have a central one at
the top
they've been working on ones at each
corner that do you know they just work
together to form the full arc
they'll figure it out i mean make the
styles work a little harder they can
figure out how to incorporate these
things in there they can do it i mean i
think i don't so i
i completely appreciate the um worries
that you're mentioning
uh with these the difficulties with all
these sensory modalities
but it does i'm going to guess that
these are solvable problems
um a lot of technology i mean it might
be cautionary for the time scale
that it will take us to solve them i
guess what i wonder is
uh it sounds like a complicated problem
are we do we have like
really smart programmers trying to
uh write code that will help the car
turn all this information into a map of
its environment or are we sort of
doing the deep learning thing where we
just train it and
uh it the car the the ai system or
whatever figures out for itself
how to convert uh that data into a map
do you know
i think well i think it's a combination
of both from what i've been able to see
the way the industry's moving
it seems to be a combination of both
there's definitely very clever programs
working on these problems
but there's also an awful lot of um
importance put into the number of miles
of training that these cars do tesla
likes to talk about how many millions of
miles
their cars have racked up with their
autopilot set up
google and waymo have been driving cars
around constantly
mapping and trying and testing and
they're doing the deep learning kind of
method for that so i think
it's a combination and i feel like right
now the big players are putting
it seems like they're putting more at
least more visible effort
into uh the deep learning training
getting them to drive
just brute forcing as much data in there
as possible
what could possibly go wrong yeah i
can't imagine how
this could be terribly disastrous
and you know the other thing is like we
were talking about before there's so
many
i feel like there's a lot of things that
aren't being
addressed like you've driven in new york
i imagine like in new york city i have
not
and i don't think i ever have i've been
in new york plenty of times but like you
know look i
i drive in california i'm a wimp when i
move back to the east coast where i'm
from
like i i leave that for other people
well driving in new york or any there's
a lot of big cities like this it's a
different
kind of thing um if you're at a
intersection with
pedestrians around which in like middle
manhattan is pretty much everywhere
there's an interesting process that
happens so
i haven't even noticed i don't even know
if it matters what the light is showing
or the walk or
not walk lights and sometimes it just
doesn't matter but there's a dance where
some massive pedestrians will be going
across and if the driver has a green
light i guess that if they feel like
they want to go through
they kind of inch forward into the scrum
of people
and they're basically driving into the
crowd of people until there's some
breaking point where people decide
okay let's let the car through and they
back off but for some period of time
you're driving into a crowd of people
very very slowly but you're doing it how
do you program a car to do that
how do you program a car to say drive
like you're gonna run over a whole lot
of people
but don't really mean it and the way it
works is again there's a lot of
communication between
driver and people through the windshield
you're looking at the eyes of the person
in there
at some point there's a this kind of
negotiation that happens
within seconds and you know then one or
both goes through so like the driver
ends up going or then they pause and
then the people go by but there's a
constant negotiation
that's very human and it's there's
communication there human to human
communication that i think is going to
be
really difficult to program into a car
and
you know also when it comes to like
people crossing streets
we immediately see like a mom with a
holding a little kid's hand at the
corner of a street like a crazy little
toddler and we know
because we're people that toddler could
do something bonkers at any moment and
you're just less predicted
or you see someone who's clearly crazy
who's just like acting weird and all of
a sudden we're like
be ready for someone to act weird that's
that's a lot to ask out of a
computer learning system and that's the
part where i think things get dicey
well i've also driven in india which is
completely bonkers and i have no idea
how the hell that would work i've been
i've i've been in places you know i
uh i've been in um i mean paris and
london are pretty bad to be honest we
don't need to go
to very exotic places but i've been in
southeast asia also i've not been to
india but yeah the
local norms are all different you know
la and san francisco have different
local norms and
uh for driving and it does matter a lot
india is like
india is basically brownian motion
somehow it's just
if you think of the molecules flowing
and things somehow
not everyone's dead it works but i've
driven in the end i've been driven in
india and it's terrifying like people
will drive
into oncoming traffic in the other lane
because the road is smoother on that
side
and they won't even move over until you
can like read the watch of the guy
coming towards you and then
i mean i was on this off-road rally
there and it's the only time in my life
i've been driving and like
driving this um mahindra thar which is
like a jeep in like these sand dune kind
of conditions that was actually very
tricky to drive
and there were brief stretches of road
it's the only time where i've ever
gotten off a paved road
onto dirt and rocks and thought oh thank
god
now i can relax but it's all because
those are not our local conditions like
i had a friend in boston who's like
it's all the tourists who make it
dangerous here because they drive at the
speed limit and try to obey rules and
it's just not what everyone else is
doing they're they're
fish out of water exactly but anyway i
think yes i do want to get to the
the fun part of your book because what
you know it's sort of
there's a couple of uh not very hidden
agendas there and one of them is to
think about
the design you know the the fact that
once you have a truly autonomous vehicle
it's not a car anymore and and we're
being held back by this idea that
we're thinking of autonomous cars as
basically cars
but they're going to drive themselves
and what you're saying is once you're
not driving it
there's a whole new universe of
possibilities for what to do that opens
up
yeah it's it's a robot i mean that's the
thing we have to really
we have to stop thinking about them as
cars once once
we get to these level four or five
vehicles that don't even have produce
provisions for a human to drive it's
something completely different it's no
longer a car it's a transportation robot
and really what people want has very
little to do with how cars are designed
now like if you think about it
the way we design cars now it's like a
set of bleachers
two rows and they're both facing forward
why would you want that
if you're not driving like you would
want a little room really yeah you want
a little room on wheels and you want to
be able to do
anything in that little room like you'll
want to be able to sometimes have it
open windows and sometimes you'll want
the you'll want complete privacy because
you're doing filthy things in there
because
people will because it's going to be
your own
private space you're not going to want
to sit facing forward you would want
you know like couches or people facing
each other maybe you're going to want to
sleep in that thing
you're going to work do whatever it's
just it's no longer a car
it's a mobile room that's a robot that
takes you where you want to be
i was definitely uh surprised to learn
in your book that honda has already
made uh a love car yes
yeah oh yeah i love that you got the
honda and what's amazing is that it was
it was the smx and it was actually so
and you have to understand the
circumstances
of the japanese market to really get it
because it was because it was
marketed it was a k-class car which is a
special class of small car
that you don't have to pay the same
taxes on in japan so it's designed
to be sold in dense cities like tokyo
privacy
is a precious commodity in a city like
tokyo
especially if you're a young person
who's not quite out on your own let's
say you're
18 to 22 or something like that you have
a girlfriend but you still live at home
the idea of a small volume of space that
is just yours
is extremely valuable for all the filthy
reasons you're probably thinking of
and honda knew this and they actually
advertised this car
with like love based terms and it was
all like tongue-in-cheek
everything like it would fold flat into
like a very nice little double bed
with all the seats folded down and they
knew exactly what they were doing and
all the advertising
was basically mobile love hotel
unashamedly
when was this made what's that
when was this oh this it was made in the
i think this is in the
recently like this is a late 90s early
2000s vehicles sounds like 70s
but um what's that it sounds so 70s to
me but i guess
okay it could be more recent than that
well i mean we had that in the 70s too
the big van the custom van craze of the
70s yeah with the shag carpet that was
basically the american version of the
same same thing but the
car was like it was a regular car with
seats
but then the seats you would basically
fold into a bed this is this is just
what i think is amazing and maybe i'm
surprised it didn't catch on i don't
know
yeah i think i think they sold a lot of
these i mean and the fundamental design
is still popular
for this class of car in japan which is
um they call them tall boys they're
basically like little
cubes they have like um set restrictions
for the length and width of this class
of car
so they basically just maximize that
volume and you just drive these little
cubicle
cars and they hold a surprising amount
of space inside the volume in the
interior is great
so i'm sure they were used for this
purpose long before honda just thought
screw it let's just
make a card specifically but this is um
this is an inspiration when we're
thinking about you know how things are
going to change if you don't need to
worry about driving the car i mean i
presume that for the love car the idea
was
you would park but uh now you're saying
that you know the whole idea of
engine in front forward-facing passenger
compartment then trunk in the back
you don't need to think in those terms
anymore you can be much more
open about what you want the space
inside to be like
exactly and i think flexibility is going
to be crucial i mean if you
if you are actually okay i mean there's
a lot of people who believe
that autonomous vehicles will be
something that uh people don't own
they'll all be like ubers or something
like that
i think in certain areas that's probably
true but i think that's more true
for places where car ownership is rare
now big cities like
new york london you know paris that kind
of thing
um but i think in places like la having
your own
car is it's it's different like it's
your own like
people store stuff in their cars it's
like a locker it's you know if you
work you know far from home like and you
you may take a break in your car because
it's like your own space i think
people will still desire their own
private personal car
if you have kids you know that this is
true because
there's so much crap that's associated
especially when they're really little
that you just have to keep with you and
it doesn't it's not feasible the idea of
lugging all this crap and kid seats and
stuff to put an uber
you want your own car so in that sense i
think there will still be private
ownership of autonomous vehicles
i think they'll be very flexible boxy
things
exterior wise they're going to because
that's just the easiest way
to encapsulate the most volume in a
given area
so and i think the interiors will fold
out and do all kinds of different things
all kinds of crash protection is going
to have to be figured out volvo's
already working on
chrome seat belts so like you know
restraint systems for when you're laying
in a bed
um maybe we'll decide at some point
these things are safe enough we don't
have to worry about that anymore
um maybe we'll just have more advanced
you know supplemental systems like
airbag systems just flood the interior
with a foam so you're not going to move
something but people want they're going
to want flexibility
they're going to want to maximize the
time in the car
and they're not even going to think
about it in terms of traveling it's a
room
whatever you may do in a room you're
going to want to be able to do while
you're in motion
and i don't really see the point of
any other way also the idea of
performance changes like
why would like doesn't like the id like
performance cars that we know about now
we drive partially because
we get a visceral feeling of enjoyment
from driving the car
and there's a statement that says i can
handle this amount of power a car that
handles like this
if you're not driving who cares that
doesn't
that's not a thing anymore um so i think
status will always be a thing when it
comes to how they're styled but i think
the
the interior space will become arguably
more important than the exterior i mean
exterior will still be important because
people still like
to convey things with their cars but
these are going to be
vehicles designed from the inside out as
opposed to today where
while the inside's important you know
the variants of exterior design
are huge right now i think we're going
to be entering an era of vans
and era vans well i think the most basic
sort of
psychological change is the idea that
the
front row seats can be facing backwards
right i mean and maybe put a little
table in there and you know you can
enjoy your coffee along the way and
uh do the crossword whatever it is we've
seen this before in some things there
yeah anything any work surfaces tables
eating
whatever you're going to want to do it
like why why wouldn't you if you're not
driving
there's just no point in staring and
sitting facing forward i mean
the reason we do it in things like
trains and buses is just because of
um you know amount of people you can
cram into a given area in airplanes
i mean if we you know if we had our way
and if space wasn't such a big
issue you would be able to you know move
around and do whatever and you know like
um
when it came time to move from los
angeles and i moved my family to north
carolina
so for that move to make it a little
more fun i bought an rv
in l.a i got like a 5 000 rv and it was
in actually beautiful shape
and it had like a kitchen and a bathroom
with a bathtub and a toilet and
you know and i put in a little flat
screen tv and hooked up a wii and all
this stuff and
and so we drove across country and i
ended up driving like 99 of the time but
my wife and kid
were just lounging in the back like it
was a little
room and that's the closest i can think
of like in in this instance they had an
autonomous vehicle
i was the computer and the cameras were
my eyes but i was basically that
and they just had the best time hanging
out back there making pizza rolls in the
oven and
using the bat like when it comes to a
luxury vehicle there is no greater
luxury
than taking a comfortable satisfying
dump wherever you feel like it
in your own car that's that's far better
than any rolls-royce and it's
you see the appeal of it like a room on
wheels is the way these things are going
to go
but i'm also interested in the how
design will
reflect the fact if we do have something
like the
all autonomous ubers model where you
don't
i mean maybe some people will own their
cars for various reasons uh both
romantic and practical
but one of the huge weird things about
cars right now
is there's an enormous number of
four-seater cars driven by one person
at a time right and if it's just
uh you know a set of autonomous vehicles
that are basically like ubers or taxis
and you can call them
then probably it's gonna be a lot of
one-person vehicles and a lot of uh
special purpose vehicles you can call
for whatever reason does that
is that a sensible economically feasible
model you think
i think so because i think i mean it's
even worse now if you think about it
because not only are there like four
seat cars there's usually by and large
4c
suvs which is even crazier if you think
about one person
in a you know 5 500 pound off-road
vehicle with
gigantic tires like it's wildly
inefficient really
so i think the idea that there will be
like one or two-person little podlet
kind of things
that are uber style that take you place
to place that's very reasonable and
chances are most of these vehicles will
be electric which means that um
you know from a technical standpoint
most electric cars right now
are being built on this kind of
skateboard idea meaning all the
batteries are flat in the bottom
the motors are actually really small and
can just be basically in line with the
wheels either at the front of the rear
and they're very easy to make modular
almost every major auto manufacturer
right now is developing a modular
uh skateboard type chassis for their
vehicles volkswagens for example
is called meb and they have basically
one fundamental electric platform that's
going to be everything from
a two-door golf to the new microbus the
electric microbus that they're planning
so
this is how it's going to be so the idea
that making a
small two passenger car or a force
even six passenger car for like you know
replaced like bus replacement kind of
things or more
um they're all modular type systems it
will make a lot of sense for them to do
that and i think you'll certainly see a
lot of it and i think a lot of
the dispersion of how many of each size
of the car will depend on
the particular market like some markets
are going to be more communal group
type of um you know like buses or sub
scale buses kind of thing
and some places are going to be more one
or two passenger thing yeah i think a
one passenger one is unlikely i think
two is about as small as they'll get
because
by the time you're building for one it's
easy enough to just add a second seat in
there and people
are as likely to travel in pairs as they
are singly so i think they'll have like
two
two four six eight and then you know bus
size things and i think
uh it'll be easy enough to build those
in whatever quantities
make sense well and also zero person
things this is what something you talked
about which i i
embarrassingly had never really thought
of but there's going to be a lot of
autonomous delivery vehicles with
no people in them at all yeah yeah and i
think actually that's going to be
i think that could actually come even
quicker than human-carrying vehicles and
i think this is actually
in a lot of ways a lot better because if
you think about it all of the
well many of the errands we make if you
have if an
autonomous vehicle is taking you there
you really would start to wonder
why do i even have to go at all like it
might even be better
to have an autonomous car that you can't
get in just for quality of life
like there's no reason why if you had an
autonomous
vehicle that was basically the size of a
pickup truck bed it was like small
and it had remote opening compartments
and you could just tell it to go places
like you basically go to the website of
a grocery store
you put in what you want from your
grocery list and then you send your car
over and the grocery store already has a
system in place when your stuff's ready
the car gets summoned they put it in you
maybe get a camera that automatically
takes a picture of what's in there and
sends it to your phone so you can
confirm
you hit okay it comes home like you have
to go out for tampons at 2 a.m
you shouldn't have to do that you you
just send the car out with some
instructions it goes to the cvs
automated pod area
it picks them up and it comes back home
there's no reason why this can't happen
it's the exact same technology the
engineering's even easier because you
don't have to worry about the people
inside
these things would be small relatively
cheap i've even
in the book i even talk about how i
would love to have one as someone who
has a bunch of old
cars you know i've got an old 73 beetle
that i drive around a lot
and it's getting old enough that you
know on trips it would be great if i
could have this thing follow me
with spare parts in it if i want to take
a long trip and even to tow me out of
situations if i just get stuck
somewhere like it could be a huge boon
to people with classic cars
these would just be literal errand
robots yeah
and i think there's all kinds of reasons
why these make a ton of sense maybe even
i don't i i'm almost more excited for
those than i would be just because i
like to drive
but there's plenty of times i just don't
feel like like if i want to drive
and that's the other thing like when
autonomous cars come if there's
human-driven cars still
they're going to be fun human-driven
cars because all of the mundane driving
you can hand off to a machine either an
unmanned errand bot
or your commuting machine to go to work
but if you like i feel like the only
companies that might survive
making human driven cars are ones where
it's enjoyable lotus
perversely may still be around or morgan
or these companies that make
cars that are all about the visceral
enjoyment of driving um
i think it'll be niche but it'll still
be there because i think that's still
something
people will want well you make that you
make the wonderful point uh
that the design of actual human be
human-driven automobiles over the last
few decades has become more and more
aggressive looking you know people want
their
cars to seem threatening and
intimidating and
for sort of ex-post-facto obvious
reasons
designers of fully autonomous vehicles
make them just look adorable and cute
because they don't want them to seem
threatening
yeah and i think this is this whole this
has fascinated me for a long time i'm
personally i'm just someone who
unashamedly loves cute cars
i i have no no shame or guilt about this
whatsoever that's why i always love
beetles the little nissan pow i drive is
adorable and i've always liked that i've
never felt like
i don't know there's people who are
getting secure about that thing but not
me i love it
and it's always been a little baffling
just everything now
gets an aggressive face and they claim
there's been focus groups that study
this although
i feel like psychologically it's gotta
take a toll everything every
almost every modern car now unless it's
based on a retro design like the fiat
500 or new beetle or
or something like that has a face it
looks like it wants to murder you it
looks like
an angry vacuum cleaner that just wants
to gut you and
suck up your entrails and they keep
making things like this
but when google made their autonomous
car
it looks it looks like a koala bear they
made it look like this adorable koala
bear face it's like a
freaking cartoon big round eyes but it's
but they had to do it because once these
things are driving themselves
do you really want a 4 000 pound robot
driving around
that looks like a murderbot and i
i think people would be unsettled by
that i mean it's true even the recent uh
models of the prius were styled to look
more and more aggressive and and
threatening looking and
as a previous older owner of an older
version prius i'm like what is the point
of this no one is fooled yeah
no one is threatened honestly toyota's
design recently has
i actually called uh i came up with a
name for it was a cyber oak because it's
like
there's so much going on there's like
folds and things but it has like a
mean angry fish face that just looks
like a cruel piranha
but okay i mean that's a good segue into
i think you know the final topic here
which is i think one of the not so
secret agendas behind your book which is
that
uh safety and efficiency and
visions of the utopian future aside
there are people out there including
yourself
who love driving for its own sake and
some crazy people
even love tinkering with their cars i
don't really get that but there are
people like that and
uh how can we carve out a space for that
or is it or is it just impossible i mean
probably there were people who loved
uh riding horses uh 150 years ago and
uh too bad for them yeah and the thing
is i
the horse model is something i don't
want to have happen i don't want car
people
to become like horse people because it's
difficult to keep a horse it's extremely
exclusive
and i'm gonna miss driving and i i talk
about
like one of the things i think i'm gonna
miss most i call it like the
the death of the journey in here because
in an autonomous car you get in at your
start location
you tell the robot where you want to go
and then you do
whatever the hell you want for however
long it takes and then you get out at
your destination
it's like flying in that sense or
teleportation hypothetically could be in
that
there's no middle there's just two
endpoints and some amount of time in
between
that it doesn't really relate to the
actual process
when you drive though you go on a
six-hour road trip
you're engaged with your journey the
whole time you're engaged with the
environment the whole time you see
the city fade out into farmland you see
the
the environment change you see the the
landscape
change you see things on the side of the
road you have chance encounters places
you are literally it's it's analog
you're
taking in every bit of that journey
incrementally until you get to your
destination
if you had an autonomous car you would
be on your phone or reading or doing
whatever the hell you wanted
masturbating or eating in that space of
time and it would just be point to point
and i think there's something that's
lost there the idea of a journey as an
actual journey that you experience
has value and will always have value and
there's there's no place for that in an
autonomous
future and i think about i talk about
ways to like
i think we've all just driven sometimes
without a destination
and how do you do that in an autonomous
car the first question
when you sit down in an autonomous
vehicle is where do you want to go
but i think i don't know anybody who
owns a car who hasn't at some point in
their life just thought ah
let's just get in and drive and see what
we see see where we end up
or you can go in with like a vague idea
of like i've never been to
to solvang california let's just drive
out there and see what we see
but how do you do that in an autonomous
vehicle that demands a destination
the very first thing you do and you
could probably program in
artificial ways around it you could
probably tell it you know computer
wander and then it could wander
somewhere but
cynically i feel like like companies
would sell
bits of their wandering algorithms to
put you in places where you'd see
certain restaurants or
you'd end up in the parking lot of a
best buy or some crap like that
and i don't want to see that happen
either and
uh you know i also think about you know
potential things for autonomous cars you
can download
road trips that are like curated road
trips from people and all these things
are cool
but it's still not the same you know the
the process of just
driving is also meditative
and it's the last place we have in
society
where people will leave you alone in an
autonomous car
if you know you're on a six-hour trip
somebody will be asking you to do
something in those six hours but when
you're driving
you're engaged just enough to not have
the burden of productivity on you
and yet you still have enough of your
mind free to wander
to listen to music or a book on tape or
a podcast or whatever
but you still can't nobody can expect
you to do anything other than just
driving that car and we will lose all of
that
if we lose human driving and i feel like
we don't appreciate how important those
things still are
so basically what you're saying is the
danger the real danger of autonomous
cars
is not uh that they will fail the
trolley problem and kill people but that
we'll be expected to be checking our
emails and doom scrolling on twitter the
entire time that we're commuting
exactly like is there any context where
you can imagine that that's not gonna
happen i mean if you're if people know
you have an
hour long commute and they know you're
not driving of course they're gonna
expect you to be working
yeah those should be productive hours
yeah they should be and i don't think we
need you know we still need refuges from
productivity like
we're productive an awful lot like and
driving
is that perfect mix of there's you're
doing enough with your hands and your
body
but enough of that higher part of your
brain is still free
that's why people it's like you know how
people say they come up with great ideas
in the shower or something like that
i think the driving a car is very
similar enough of your mind is freed
that you can explore ideas i do some of
my best thinking while driving in a car
oh yeah
i agree i don't want to get up you know
yeah yeah absolutely well i think
regardless of what the predictions are
for what the real future is going to be
i think these are important
considerations to keep in mind
uh in the sense that hopefully we have
some influence over the future and we
can choose to do things and i do like
you hope that
there is some space carved out for just
driving uh
even in our autonomous future i totally
agree and jason torchinski thanks so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thanks john this was a lot of fun i
really appreciate it
[Music]
you